[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes avec bruno
margolle président de la fédération des
organisations de producteurs de la pêche
bonsoir bruno margollé merci d'être avec
nous jeremy hills tous à vos côtés
représentants du parti conservateur
britannique bonsoir à vous aussi jérémy
stoops merci d'être là on l'a compris en
ce soir clairement il pourrait y avoir
un odile en tout cas les négociations
sur le break si tu patines copieusement
toujours aucun accord encadrant les
relations au poste va exciter ça semble
mal partie ce sont les anglais qui vont
échouer les négociations de charles witz
owe il faut deux parties pour échouer
est ce qu'on dit c'est ce que dit tout
le monde sait que les deux parties sont
également assez loin l'un de l'autre et
donc ce qu'il faudrait c'est que chacun
fasse suffisamment de concessions mais
pour le moment les enjeux sont trop
grands et parmi ces enjeux il faut aussi
remarquer que c'est la durée potentielle
des engagements qui font peur des deux
côtés c'est à dire chaque parti craint
de prendre des engagements dans la durée
y qui vont se révéler assez rapidement
très peu propices à son évolution
économique et donc nous attendons
toujours des pas en avant de chaque côté
tout le monde semble pessimiste en ce
moment il reste si j'ai bien compris un
peu plus de 48 heures
peut-être qu'il y aura comme souvent
dans le passé un grand coup de théâtre
au dernier moment
oui est bruno margolle vous quel est
votre sentiment ce soir quand vous
entendez ces dernières nouvelles qu'un
accord pourrait être compliqué
pour vous en aux deals ça aurait quelles
conséquences sur les pêcheurs français
justement il faut dire que on est à 22
jours de de la fin des commandes la
période de transition donc c'est c'est
quand même les états d'esprit son centre
est chassang qui saugeen que c'est très
compliqué pour pour les pêcheurs en tout
en tout cas pour les pêcheurs des des
hôtes france à tous les tous les
pêcheurs qui sont à fait aux dés à la
manche 1 on n'imagine pas à aucun
instant être comment être rejetée de 2,2
en historique de pêche depuis des
décennies ces jeux je n'imagine pas un
seul instant
donc ça serait vraiment catastrophique
pour les pêcheurs français en tout cas
de ne pas pouvoir accéder à nos zones de
pêche historique depuis des décennies je
n'imagine pas je vous dis franchement
moi je suis embarqué en 1974 depuis 1974
on évolue dans la manche
non je suis une mer du nord que côté
français côté anglais je n'imagine pas
un conte moment de ne plus pouvoir
accéder à ces zones de pêche
pourquoi j'ai rien demandé alors
justement on va essayer de mieux
comprendre ses excès aux zones de pêche
parce que ça ne peut pas être un peu
abstrait comme ça de l'extérieur c'est
l'un des points clés précisément de
cette négociation
regardez pour bien savoir à quoi ça
correspond fait un petit schéma regarder
ce petit schéma ça c'est la situation
donc actuelle les hollandais les
allemands les belges les français et les
anglais pêche tous donc dans la manche
pas de problème donc pour vous les
pêcheurs français demain avec un new
deal particulièrement voilà à quoi va
ressembler cette zone
on voit clairement le problème insuline
pour séparer les eaux anglaises des
européennes
zulte à la concentration des pêcheurs
allemands belges et hollandais le long
des côtes françaises et plus du tout
évidemment répartis dans la manche
on comprend mieux la colère des pêcheurs
français non hadjal metals les problèmes
s'étendent et de côté parce que s'il y a
un
une absence d'accord les pêcheurs
britanniques vont se retrouver avec
plein de poissons qu'ils auront du mal à
vendre parce qu'il aura désormais des
des taxes d'importation sur le continent
donc encore une fois les deux parties
ont tous les deux intérêt à faire un pas
en avant et à se rencontrer au milieu en
fait les discussions assez complexe
parce que non seulement on parle
d'autres territoriale et de poissons
mais on essaie aussi de diviser les
types de poissons la profondeur des
mères etc etc
on se demande si s'il sera possible d'en
venir à bout dans les 48 heures qui
restent à moi que à moins que la pêche
la pêche ne reste un enjeu uniquement
parce que on n'a pas encore réglé
les autres questions c'est à dire les
questions des règles sur la concurrence
en général
et puis les mécanismes de règlement de
conflits c'est la pêche est juste à un
élément que contient en otage peut-être
qu'il y aura une solution à mon avis je
persiste à croire que l'absence d'accord
le no deal
même si tout le monde est pessimiste ce
serait de la folie et qu'on n'ira pas
jusque là
bruno marc gales vous dites quoi aux
anglais vous ce soir il faut absolument
trouver un accord c'est ce sera de la
concurrence déloyale jusqu'au bout j'y
croire madame jusqu'au bout j'ai fait
confiance à nos négociateurs
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec avec
comment stéphane jeu puisque les mauges
et percussions jérémy pardon mais je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec lui qu'il
faut à tout prix trouver un deal n'est
pas à n'importe quel prix tout
simplement je pense que des deux côtés
il ya des deux côtés de la manche il ya
d'un côté ils ont accès au marché d'un
autre côté nous on a accès aux zones de
pêche et je pense que c'est très
important pour les deux côtés ça serait
catastrophique pour eux aussi bien pour
le royaume uni que pour pour comment le
l'union européenne ce serait
catastrophique d'arriver à new deal et
je vois l'om on appelle à penser section
sur deux problèmes de cohabitation
ça fait 15 ans 20 ans pour que les
pêcheurs deux de chaque côté de la
manche font des efforts de pour la
sélectivité pour améliorer les stocks de
poisson et j'ai bien peur que l'absence
de négociations pas de doute il ferait
que dans quelques mois voir on mettrait
tout à plat dans l'espace de quelques
mois
j'ai simplement oui en tout cas au bord
du gouffre un londres et bruxelles pour
l'instant sont pas vraiment sur votre
ligne à izon exclut toute reprise des
négociations après le 31 donc beaucoup
de pression c'est ce qu'a déclaré le
porte parole du premier ministre
écoutent et nous sommes prêts à négocier
tant qu'il reste du temps disponible
si nous pensons qu'un accord reste
possible mais il peut exclure une
reprise des négociations l'année
prochaine jeremy hobbs on comprend que
vous avez quand même un petit peu pitié
non pêcheurs français me quand même un
new deal vous arrangerez en tout cas sur
ce problème précis de la pêche quand on
voit ce schéma reims au graphique on a
vu tout à l'heure ce sacre est un petit
peu les yeux quand même un odile
n'arrange personne sur quoi que ce soit
s'il s'agissait uniquement d'un accord a
négocié entre la france et le royaume
uni sur la pêche je pense qu'on aurait
déjà trop
la solution il y a longtemps en même
temps quand on entend ces déclarations
que ce soit des britanniques ou de la
part de bruxelles
ce sont des déclarations de fin de
négociation et donc on peut s'attendre à
ce que chacun dise il n'y aura pas de
concession où on n'ira pas au delà du 31
et c'est à dire etc
on verra bien on verra bien parce
qu'encore une fois ce serait vraiment
idiot de ne pas trouver une solution
même temporaire même en attendant
quelque chose de beaucoup plus développé
du complet comme accor on verra bien le
suspens en tout cas reste entier puisque
jamais merci à tous les neuf bruno
margollé était avec nous pour débattre
notamment de l'accès aux zones de pêche
alors que les négociations patinent sur
le front du break site merci à tous les
deux